I have such respect for the Justin
Bieber's in the one direction
that's Nick Lachey opening up to et's
Jennifer perros on Thursday about his
rise to fame with 98 degrees in the late
90s
specifically why he's thankful the band
made it before social media having that
kind of Fame at a young age with all the
social media attention and pressure I
just came to imagine dealing with what
they deal with so much respect to those
people these days
Nick drew Jeff and Justin all have
social media accounts hopefully we'll
see plenty of snaps from there my 2k
tour this summer they're hitting the
road with O'Town dream and Ryan Cabrera
what makes it different now than let's
say almost 20 years ago when you first
started aside from the bad knees and and
back pain and no I think it's a
perspective it's it's we were in such a
whirlwind back in those days and it was
like holding on for dear life and a lot
of great memories and a lot of great you
know times back then I think now we all
have you know in a different place in
life we have a different perspective the
42 year old singer married his wife
Vanessa Lachey in 2011 they welcomed
their son Camden in 2012 and daughter
Brooklyn in 2015 are you bringing the
family on tour uh no actually none of us
to bring in our families on the road
this time it's just uh it's just us on
the tour bus like the old days so I will
actually be missing my my five-year
wedding anniversary because I'll be with
these Schmucks out on the road somewhere
so I expect a big cuddle after the show
you